BAT WITH THE ANGLE.
AT DECODING THE LEFT, THAT IS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
71 YEARS AGO, GEORGE OH, WELL,
WROTE ABOUT THE MANIPULATION OF
LANGUAGE AND POLITICS.
WENT ON TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
PRESENT POLITICAL CHAOS IS
CONNECTED WITH THE DECAY OF
LANGUAGE.
POLITICAL LANGUAGE IS DESIGNED
TO MAKE LIFE SOUND TRUTHFUL AND
MURDER RESPECTABLE AND TO GIVE
AN APPEARANCE OF SOLIDITY TO
MERE WINS.
AT THE TIME, GEORGE ORWELL WAS
WRITING ABOUT THE RISE OF
COMMUNISM IN FAR LEFT THOUGHT.
TODAY WITH THE RISE OF THE HARD
LEFT IN AMERICA, WE SHOULD KEEP
ORWELL’S WARNINGS IN MIND AND
LEARN TO SPOT LIES THAT ARE MADE
TO SOUND TRUTHFUL DURING THIS
PIVOTAL TIME.
NOW, LUCKY FOR YOU, WE ARE HERE
AND WE ARE GOING TO HELP DECODE
AND TRANSLATE THE LANGUAGE OF
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
ALLIES THIS CAMPAIGN SEASON.
FIRST UP, WHAT THEY’RE SAYING
ABOUT VIRUS STRATEGY.
>> THEY NEED LEADERSHIP, THEY
NEED A PLAN.
>> I WISH WE HAD A NATIONAL
PLAN.
>> EVERYONE IS CONFUSED.
THIS IS THE TIME WE SHOULD BE
TALKING TO ONE VERY CLEAR, VERY
CONSISTENT VOICE.
>> WEARS THE NATIONAL STRATEGY,
WHERE’S THE NATIONAL LEADERSHIP?
IT DOESN’T EXIST.
>> Laura: OKAY, TRANSLATION.
WHEN THEY SAY NATIONAL STRATEGY,
THEY MEAN NATIONAL LOCKDOWN.
IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT THEY
WANT TO SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY UNTIL THE VIRUS EITHER
MAGICALLY DISAPPEARS ON ITS OWN
OR UNTIL THERE IS AN EFFECTIVE
STATE VACCINE, WHICH EVEN
DR. FAUCI HAS TO SAY MAY NEVER
COME.
AND THINK ABOUT CUOMO FOR A
MOMENT.
WITH HIS DEADLY COVID RECORD, HE
SHOULD BE RUN OUT OF POLITICS
FOREVER, NOT BE HELD UP AS SOME
KIND OF ANTI-TRUMP SUPERHERO.
AND HERE IS YOUR NIGHTLY
REMINDER, NEW YORK DEATHS
ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY A QUARTER OF
ALL DEATHS IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY HAVE HAD NEARLY 13 TIMES
MORE DEATHS PER 100,000 THAN
TEXAS AND SEVEN AND A HALF TIMES
MORE THAN FLORIDA.
NOW RECALL ALSO THAT CALIFORNIA,
SPEAKING OF STRATEGY, THEY
INSTITUTED A STRICT LOCKDOWN AND
THEY STILL HAVE RISING
INFECTIONS.
THAT OBVIOUSLY DIDN’T WORK.
IT PROLONGED THE INEVITABLE, SO
THE NATIONAL LEADERSHIP THEY ARE
CRAVING FOR HAS TO BE JUST
ANOTHER LOCKDOWN.
AT THIS TIME IN NATIONAL
LOCKDOWN.
MATT, NO EXCEPTIONS.
AND BIDEN CAN’T ADMIT THIS.
OF COURSE HE CAN’T IN THE MEDIA
IS NOT GOING TO PRESS HIM ON IT,
CERTAINLY NOT FOR ANY SPECIFICS
OF HIS SOLUTION BECAUSE THEY
KNOW IT’S NOT POPULAR.
BUT MOVING ON, DECODING THE
DEMOCRATS ON RACE.
>> AMERICANS ARE IN THE STREETS
DEMANDING RACIAL JUSTICE.
>> I THINK THAT THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FOR OUR COUNTRY MOVING
FORWARD IS TO GUARANTEE
HEALTH CARE, PAY A LIVING WAGE,
SUPPORT LABOR RIGHTS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE DOING THAT WITH
THE LENS OF RACIAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
>> NOW IS THE TIME FOR RACIAL
>> EMPOWERING GROUPS THAT
PRETEND TO CARE ABOUT MINORITIES
JUST END UP PROFITING THEMSELVES
BY STOKING RACIAL ANIMOSITY?
UNDER A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
DECISIONS WILL BE MADE LARGELY
BASED ON RATE, NOT ON MERIT OR
HARD WORK OR ACHIEVEMENT.
THOSE WORDS THEMSELVES COME FROM
WHITE PRIVILEGE, THEY ARE
TELLING US NOW.
GET READY FOR MASSIVE
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST I DON’T
KNOW, MORE THAN 100 MILLION
AMERICANS.
SPECIAL PRIVILEGES,
ACCOMMODATIONS AND MONEY ARE
DOLED OUT TO CERTAIN POLITICALLY
PREFERRED GROUPS.
AND ON FOREIGN POLICY, DEMOCRATS
SAY THEY ARE GOING TO NEED TO
REBUILD ALL OF OUR INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
SPEAK OF THE CHALLENGE FOLLOWING
THIS DISASTROUS WILL NOT JUST BE
TO RESTORE OUR CREDIT
MELODY AND REPUTATION.
IT WILL BE AN ACTIVE
FORWARD-LOOKING FOREIGN POLICY
FOR THE WORLD AS WE FIND IT
TODAY.
>> Laura: TRANSLATION: GET
READY FOR ANOTHER APOLOGY TOUR.
BIDEN IS GOING TO GO AROUND THE
WORLD BEGGING AMERICA’S PARDON.
AFTER ALL, HAVING A PRESIDENT
WHO ACTUALLY FOUGHT FOR AND
FIGHTS FOR AMERICAN WORKERS AND
IS TOUGH ON TRADE IS NOT GIVING
AWAY THOSE SCORE LIKE OBAMA DID.
YOU THINK THE EUROPEANS LIKE
THAT?
THAT IS WHY EUROPE WOULD
PROBABLY LOVE A BIDEN
PRESIDENCY, BECAUSE THEY KNOW
HE’LL DO PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING
EUROPE WANTS.
AND AS FAR AS CHINA IS
CONCERNED, REMEMBER BIDEN SAID
THEY WEREN’T EVEN A THREAD.
EXPECT THE DISMANTLING OF ALL
TARIFFS, HUGE CONCESSIONS BY THE
UNITED STATES AND THE CONTINUED
OUTSOURCING OF AMERICAN JOBS.
WHAT ABOUT HEALTH CARE?
IT’S STILL THE OLD "IF YOU LIKE
YOUR PLAN, YOU CAN KEEP IT."
>> HEALTH CARE IS A GUARANTEED
HUMAN RIGHT, BUT TAKING AWAY THE
RIGHT TO HAVE A PRIVATE PLAN IF
YOU WANT A PRIVATE PLAN, I
DISAGREE WITH.
>> Laura: HERE’S A MEMBER OF
BIDEN’S OWN UNITY HEALTH CARE
TASK FORCE TALKING ABOUT HOW SHE
AND THE PROGRESSIVES WERE ABLE
TO MOVE BIDEN TO THE LEFT.
>> WE DID A LOT OF GOOD WORK
TOGETHER TO REALLY PUSH THE
VICE PRESIDENT HEALTH CARE
PLATFORM MUCH FURTHER THAN IT’S
BEEN BEFORE, TO TAKE ELEMENTS OF
MEDICARE FOR ALL AND PUT IT INTO
THE PLATFORM.
>> Laura: INTO THE PLATFORM.
OF COURSE, THEY MEAN GOVERNMENT
RUN HEALTH CARE.
THEY’VE ALREADY EMBRACED FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, AND I THINK TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT’S IN
STORE FOR US, LOOK NO FURTHER
THAN THIS CHILLING ACCOUNT FROM
"THE GUARDIAN" NEWSPAPER TODAY.
IT WAS WRITTEN BY A WOMAN WITH
LATE STAGE CANCER BETTER DELAYED
TREATMENT FROM THE NATIONAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICE.
THE OPERATION FINALLY TOOK PLACE
ON THE 27TH OF FEBRUARY, ALMOST
FIVE MONTHS AFTER THE CANCER HAD
RECURRED.
ONCE HE HAD TAKEN A LOOK INSIDE,
MY SURGEON CLOSED MAY BEGIN WITH
A HEAVY HEART.
IT WAS NOW IMPOSSIBLE TO REMOVE
ALL THE CANCEROUS TISSUE.
THEY GOT THERE TOO LATE.
THE HEARTBREAK.
ON TAXES, THEY ARE SELLING THE
SAME STALE LINES.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD RAISE TAXES
ON THE WEALTHY.
>> PASS A WEALTH TAX AND PROTECT
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> PATEL MILLIONS OF WOULD-BE
ENTREPRENEURS GET OUT FROM UNDER
THEIR DEBT AFTER THEY START
BUSINESSES, AND IT’S TIME
CORPORATE AMERICA PAID
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF TAXES.
>> Laura: FAIR SHARE?
TRANSLATION: IT’S BACK TO THE
FAILED POLICIES OF THE ’70s
WHERE THE TOP RATES ARE GOING TO
BE 70%.
IT’S NOT JUST GOING TO BE FOR
CORPORATIONS.
OF COURSE THE TAX RATE THAT HIGH
JUST HURTS WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
WOMEN.
WALL STREET BANKERS AND
LOBBYISTS CAN ALWAYS FIND WAYS
AROUND PAYING THESE ABSORBENT
RATES BUT THAT IS THEIR PLAN, TO
PUNISH EVERYONE WHO WORKS FOR A
LIVING, THEN DOLE OUT THE MONEY
THEY HAVE TWO PROGRAMS LIKE, I
DON’T KNOW, LET’S GO BACK TO
MIDNIGHT BASKETBALL.
THE TAX POLICY CENTER ESTIMATED
THAT JOE BIDEN’S AGENDA WOULD
RAISE TAXES BY $4 TRILLION OVER
THE NEXT DECADE.
MORE THAN TWICE AS BIG A TAX
RAISE AS PROPOSED BY
HILLARY CLINTON IN 2016.
AND SPEAKING OF FAIRNESS, THE
RICH ALREADY PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
CHECK THIS OUT, THE AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD IN THE TOP 1% RETAINS
ALMOST 18 TIMES IN TRANSFER
PAYMENTS AS THE BOTTOM FIT, BUT
PAYS MORE THAN 219 TIMES AS MUCH
IN TAXES.
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS CAMPAIGN
SEASON, I’M GOING TO BE DOING
MORE DECODING FOR YOU BUT I HAVE
TO ADMIT, THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
IN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY WHO REALLY
ARE SAYING WHAT THEY MEAN.
>> THEY ARE CRITICIZING, WHY USE
THE WORD DEFINED, WHY USE THE
WORD DEFINED?
THIS IS THE WORD THAT IS COMING
FROM THE STREETS.
>> THIS IS ABOUT TRUE
REPARATIONS.
THEY HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN
SOCIETY BUT THEY NEEDN’T PLAY A
ROLE IN EVERY PARTISAN SOCIETY.
>> WE MUST BEGIN THE WORK OF
DISMANTLING THE WHOLE SYSTEM OF
OPPRESSION WHEREVER WE FIND IT.
>> Laura: THERE IS NO
TRANSLATION NEEDED HERE.
THEY’RE ACTUALLY TELLING THE
TRUTH.
THEY MEAN IT WHEN THEY SAY IT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE PLANNING,
THEY ARE ALREADY DOING IT IN
PLACES LIKE MINNEAPOLIS AND L.A.
APPEARED ON MOST BIG ISSUES IN
THE LAST YEAR, THE SQUAD HAS
BEEN THE DEMOCRATIC THOUGHT
LEADER.
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE TO DEFUNDING
THE POLICE TO CLIMATE CHANGE,
AND IT WILL ALL CONTINUE TO BE
KEY INFLUENCERS IN A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, YOU BET.
AND IF YOU THINK BIDEN IS GOING
TO STOP THEM, YOU ARE EITHER
NAIVE OR HAVEN’T BEEN PAYING ANY
ATTENTION.
BIDEN WILL BE NOTHING MORE THAN
AN OVAL OFFICE BOBBLEHEAD
NODDING ALONG WITH WHATEVER FAR
LEFTISTS APPEAR BEFORE HIM AT
ANY GIVEN TIME.
HE IS NO LONGER THE MODERATE OF
YOUR.
HE IS MOVED SO FAR LEFT TO
SATIATE THE MOB LED TO CONTINUE
DOING SO, OR ELSE THEY’RE GOING
TO SURROUND HIS HOUSE AND THEN
BURN THINGS AROUND.
AND DO YOU THINK HE’S GOING TO
CALL OUT THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
PROTECT MONUMENTS OR EVEN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
NO WAY.
IT WILL GET HIM OUT THROUGH THE
TUNNEL.
I’M CONFIDENT, DESPITE ALL OF
THIS, DESPITE ALL THE DECODING
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO DO THAT,
FALL, MANY MORE AMERICANS WILL
UNDERSTAND THE ORWELLIAN CHASM
THAT YOU’RE GOING TO GET THROWN
INTO UNDER A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
WOULDN’T YOU RATHER BE DECODING